Music
Single sign on
So what's the concept of single sign on?
It's this idea that a user can enter one set of credentials and magically get access to a whole bunch of different systems.
Here's what it basically looks like.
We've got our user system here.
They enter their one set of credentials into the authentication server.
And then they magically get access to a whole bunch of other systems out there.
That's the theory.
That's the idea of single sign on.
So what are the pros and cons of this?
Well, I mean, users love it.
They don't have to remember all these different passwords.
And so potentially they might remember instead of having to remember 10 crappy passwords,
they'll maybe remember one better password, although in my experience that doesn't usually happen.
It also allows for centralized administration.
If you want to create, modify, someone's account, remove someone's account on a whole bunch of systems.
If you're using a single sign on system, it's much easier to do so.
What are the downsides, the cons?
Well, it's absolutely a single point of failure from both an availability and a compromise perspective.
Now let's look at the basics of how any of these single sign on systems work.
The basic idea here is that our user wants to get access to the application.
In order to get access to the application, they'll have to authenticate which the authentication server.
So our user here is going to send a login request to the application.
If our user is currently authenticated if they have a valid ticket or token,
then they'll probably be let right in.
But let's assume that our user doesn't currently have a valid ticket or token.
What's going to happen?
Well, they'll be redirected back.
And then they'll be redirected back to the authentication server.
And what will they do with the authentication server?
Authenticate through knowledge, ownership, characteristic or some combination thereof.
Once they've authenticated with the authentication server, they'll be provided with a ticket or token
and redirected back to the application.
The application will then read the assertion statements, the contents of that ticket or token,
and make an authorization decision as to whether or not that user is able to actually access the application.
So that at a basic level is how any of these single sign-on type systems work.
So now let's look at one particular technology that enables single sign-on, Kerberos.
Kerberos is a pretty old technology, pretty old protocol, and frankly not very good,
but it is commonly pervasively used with an organization to enable single sign-on.
And the reason it's used so pervasively, even though it's not great, it's built into Microsoft products.
It's been used for years, it's just become a standard.
And so why is it called Kerberos?
There's a fun little bit of history behind this.
So in Greek mythology, there's the three-headed dog, Cerberos, guarding the gates to Hades.
And so the creators of Kerberos were creating a protocol that would have sort of three major capabilities,
accounting, authentication, and auditing.
And so they thought of it as a three-headed dog, and so they decided to call it Kerberos.
So let's look at how Kerberos works.
And if you've ever read about Kerberos in a book to figure out all the various pieces of it,
and how ticket-granting tickets, and ticket-granting servers, and KDCs, and anything else fits together,
it's a bit of a nightmare.
So let me try and make it as simple as possible, and highlight just the most key aspects that you need to know about Kerberos.
So first of all, with Kerberos, we have our client here, and we have the service that our client eventually wants to access here.
And in order to access that service, the first thing that our user or client here is going to do, in this case, Alice,
she's going to go to what's called the authentication service, the AS.
And what the AS is going to return back to her is an encrypted ticket-granting ticket, a TGT.
Now, this TGT, this ticket-granting ticket, is encrypted with her password, with Alice's password.
So what Alice decrypts the ticket-granting ticket with is her password.
So now she has a copy of the ticket-granting ticket, and she now makes a request to the ticket-granting service, the TGS.
And what she says to the TGS is, here's my ticket-granting ticket, here's my user information, and here's the service that I want access to.
And then the TGT-granting service will make a decision, and if it decides that she's going to have access, it will return Alice a service ticket.
And it's finally this service ticket that Alice can use to go and access the service that she wants to access.
A few important things here. This ticket or token contains some assertion statements, some information, like Alice's username, and some other assertion statements like that.
But very importantly, does it contain Alice's password or her other authentication credentials? No.
Because you do not want all your different services, your different systems out there, to know Alice's password.
The only system we want to know Alice's password is the authentication service.
Now there's one more bit of terminology you should know here, and that is that these two pieces, the authentication service and the ticket-granting service, are typically sort of bundled together and called the Key Distribution Center, the KDC.
So those are the major pieces of Kerberos that you need to know.
Now let's talk about two major issues with Kerberos. The first is that it only supports symmetric cryptography.
Now of course, we've talked about the major problem with symmetric cryptography is both Key Distribution and the number of keys that you need grows exponentially.
The more systems there are, the environment. So it can be quite difficult to manage the keys in a Kerberos environment because of the fact that only supports symmetric cryptography.
The other issue is that it only supports one ticket-granting ticket. Here's why that's an issue.
It's a very good practice in security to expire someone's access or force them to reauthenticate at a particular interval depending on the value of the system, the more valuable the system, the more often you want that person to reauthenticate.
The same idea applies to Kerberos. So if we want to force a user to reauthenticate, we would expire their ticket.
And let's say they have access to 10 different systems, and one of those systems is a really high-value system.
So you're going to expire that ticket based on the frequency necessary for the really high-value system, maybe every 10 minutes.
But here's the problem. Let's say that our user, even though they have access to the high-value system, they're not using that system.
They're over here using the company Wiki or something, which is a super low-value system, and it would probably be fine if they reauthenticated every decade.
But the problem is because that ticket-granting ticket is set to expire based on the most valuable system, that ticket-granting ticket is going to be expiring every 10 minutes.
And our user here that's accessing this low-value system is being forced to reauthenticate every 10 minutes, very irritating the user, not great.
So those are the two major issues that you should know about Kerberos.
And there's one other major technology that enables single sign on that you need to know about, and it's called sesame, as in open sesame.
Now open sesame addresses the two major issues that we have with Kerberos.
It's those Europeans again, they looked at Kerberos, and they said, we can do better.
And they created sesame. And it addresses the two major issues with Kerberos.
It supports not only symmetric, but also asymmetric keys, and it doesn't issue just one ticket-aid issues, multiple tickets.
So you're very likely to get quite a few questions on Kerberos, so know the most about that one, and you might get one question on sesame if any.
So those are the two major protocols that enable single sign on.
Thank you.